mind if i ask you a quick question have
you noticed in the last few years that
cbd oil is [ __ ] everywhere you can
buy it at grocery stores gas stations
hair salons even your local bar mitzvahs
just about anywhere in fact 14 of
earth's surface has been permanently
dedicated to cbd oil at this point it's
basically a fiat currency but the
question that's plagued cbd enthusiasts
over the last few years is does it
really work we may never know the
meaning of life or if atlantis actually
existed or if oswald was the lone
shooter but one thing we will know today
is does cbd work one thing that does
work for sure is using science-backed
routines to develop productive habits
i'm talking about the digital coaching
app fabulous with over 30 million users
worldwide fabulous makes it easy for
anyone to develop and stick to healthy
habits if you don't sleep well or have a
hard time staying with routines fabulous
tracking feature can help you stay with
healthy habits such as a better sleep
schedule or daily reminders to stay on
track this habit tracking feature is
backed by behavioral science and is 100
personalized to allow you to go at your
own pace i do not have the best sleep
schedule i have to stay up late to
finish videos and then go to work the
next day to help with my sleep i've been
using a fabulous night it's been a great
tool in setting up a sleep schedule for
my routine per their advice they
suggested i disconnect from my phone and
computer a half hour before bed and keep
a notebook out for those late night
thoughts overall this new routine has
really helped improve my sleep and made
me more productive start building your
ideal daily routine today the first 100
people who click on the link will get 25
off a fabulous subscription
firstly we need to know the history of
cbd and how it became the ubiquitous
supplement we know today cbd or
cannabidiol is a nonpolar
phytocannabinoid from the cannabis
sativa plant known better as
it's extracted from hemp oil which comes
from the stock and stems of the cannabis
plant so it's nearly void of the
psychoactive thc cbd was first isolated
by chemist roger adams at illinois
university in 1940. by the 1980s organic
chemist rafael mccollum discovered cbd's
anti-epileptic properties and could
potentially treat seizures however with
the aggressive war on drugs emerging in
the 1970s cannabis was renamed as a
schedule 1 drug all scientific research
involving marijuana came to a screeching
halt with decriminalization and
legalization of cannabis beginning in
the mid-2000s access to cbd became much
easier and therefore research began to
take off now there's a lot of uses for
cbd oil but the main three that i found
were the most common were pain relief
anti-anxiety and treatment for seizures
this is where we put on our science hats
first off is pain relief
it's believed cbd has analgesic effects
and pain management due to its action on
inflammation several cell culture
studies in both humans and rat cells
have shown that when exposed to cbd
cells produce less pro-inflammatory
cytokines cytokines are molecules that
signal immune cells to respond to
pathogens or trauma in the body
generally immune cells respond by
inducing inflammation in the body which
then causes pain for pain relief it's
pretty straightforward if you reduce
inflammation in a chronic condition like
rheumatoid arthritis or back injury you
reduce pain several studies tested this
very theory using cbd between 2003 and
2020 seven different studies tested
cbd's effects on 600 test subjects
participants were selected based on
chronic pain conditions such as spinal
cord injury brain plexus damage
peripheral neuropathy fibromyalgia and
general chronic pain subjects were
randomized into two groups cbd versus
placebo across all studies cbd subjects
reported a significant reduction in pain
an overall improvement in quality of
life and improved sleep as opposed to
the placebo group however despite a
potential mechanism explaining pain
reduction there are two issues that
hinder cbd being a legitimate pain
reliever firstly cell culture studies
even on human cells do not entirely
translate to effective pain relieving
properties as i've mentioned before in
previous videos cell culture studies are
just a small component of the entire
formula culture tests are merely a
stepping stone in how something might
work in the human body we don't know for
sure if cytokine reduction in cell
cultures is sufficient to reduce pain in
a full-grown adult secondly there's
numerous over-the-counter pain relievers
that are known to work and are very
affordable for example there is aspirin
ibuprofen tylenol a few minutes later
and vamovo that about covers it all of
these are effective anti-inflammatory
agents that reduce pain and let's be
honest are a fraction of the price of
cbd oil without clinical trials on cbd's
pain management we can't say for sure
that it's an efficacious and
cost-effective pain reliever
what about cbd's anti-anxiety properties
in contrast to pain relief cbd has been
studied extensively for its anxiologic
effects since many anti-anxiety
medications are of the pharmaceutical
flavor and typically offer unwanted side
effects a 2021 study from the journal of
the american medical association studied
the effects of cbd on frontline medical
workers and their burnout during the
pandemic burnout was assessed using the
maslak burnout inventory which is a
psychological questionnaire that
determines mental and emotional burnout
among medical professionals teachers
social workers occupational groups and
college students 120 nurses were
randomized into two groups group one
received a placebo and standard care and
group two received 300 milligrams of cbd
and standard care both groups were
studied for 28 days as a result group 2
nurses had a significant reduction in
burnout scores at day 14 and day 28 of
the study as opposed to group 1. in a
different study this time from the
journal of neuropsychopharmacology
24 subjects diagnosed with social
anxiety disorder and 12 healthy controls
were randomized into two groups one with
placebo and one with 600 milligrams of
cbd both groups were instructed to
undergo a public speaking simulation
physiological measurements of each
subject were taken such as heart rate
blood pressure and skin conductance for
perspiration subjects with social
anxiety disorder that received cbd
before the simulation had a significant
reduction in anxiety response more so
than social anxiety subjects that did
not receive cbd it's great that cbd may
have anti-anxiety effects but why is
this the case is there any reason for
why this happens tide goes in tide goes
out you can't explain that in fact there
is the answer is an endocannabinoid
called anatomide endocannabinoids are
molecules that our body makes to help
regulate pain memory mood and stress by
binding to cannabinoid receptors these
same receptors that thc binds to
anatomize plays a major role in stress
response in humans and is known as the
bliss molecule when it binds to
cannabinoid receptors it causes a mild
feeling of bliss and euphoria making
your mood more positive and relaxed
small amounts of anatomied are also
found in chocolate which is why you may
feel a sudden positive mood when you eat
chocolate the reason why anatomy doesn't
make us feel relaxed and positive all
the time is because it has a very short
lifespan in the body as soon as it's
made it's quickly broken down by the
enzyme fatty acid amide hydrolase or
faah for short so you don't get a lot of
anatomie in your system for very long
however plot twist cbd inhibits this
enzyme and therefore delays the
breakdown of anatomies which increases
the exposure time to cannabinoid
receptors improving mood and reducing
anxiety and stress if you want hard
evidence for this here you go in 2012 a
study in the journal of frontiers and
pharmacology randomized 39 patients with
schizophrenia into two groups one group
received a missile pride and
antipsychotic medication and the other
cbd blood samples were drawn from both
groups and anatomic serum levels were
measured overall subjects who took cbd
had significantly higher levels of
anatomies in their blood and a
significant decrease in psychotic
symptoms as opposed to the mesolapride
group
one of cbd's most well-known therapeutic
benefits is its anti-seizure properties
it's believed cbd may decrease neuron
excitability therefore causing a drop in
seizure frequency and get this there's
actually clinical trial data
between 2014 and 2018 there were three
major clinical trials testing the
efficacy of cbd in treating epilepsy 550
patients with lennox gestate syndrome or
dravet syndrome two common seizure
disorders were randomized between cbd
and placebo groups and here's the
results in the first study the cbd group
had a 39.5 drop in seizures as opposed
to the placebo which only saw a 17.2
percent drop in the second study cbd
subjects had a 50 drop in convulsive
seizures the placebo group only saw a
drop of 27
additionally 5 in the cbd group were
completely seizure free as opposed to
the placebo group which was 0
in the final study the cbd group showed
a 43.9 drop in monthly seizures as
opposed to the placebo which was only
21.8 percent in 2018 the fda approved
the only cbd medication for seizure
treatment called epidialex with a cbd
concentration of 100 milligrams per
milliliter since its release on the
market epidialex has been found to
reduce seizure frequency in disorders
such as tuberous sclerosis complex linox
gustat syndrome and dravette syndrome so
there you have it cbd is effective and
has little to no side effects or so
that's what most cbd companies would
like you to believe
the fact of the matter is cbd is not
harmless and does have negative side
effects with more and more stage
legalizing marijuana the thought among
the public is if cannabis is natural and
practically harmless which is not
entirely true cbd which also comes from
cannabis must be harmless as well i mean
have you heard anything negative about
cbd at all i'm not saying cbd has
terribly negative side effects like
cocaine or chemotherapy but bad effects
in general should be known for example
in nearly all the studies previously
mentioned in this video between 10 and
20 percent of the subjects had negative
side effects after taking cbd such as
diarrhea fatigue fever nausea vomiting
and even elevated liver enzymes the
first of these aren't horrible and are
pretty common with most therapeutic
drugs however the last one elevated
liver enzymes is a big deal since cbd is
metabolized in the liver byproducts of
cbd may cause mild injury to the liver
tissue if liver enzymes are chronically
elevated for too long it can cause fatty
liver disease these side effects don't
affect the majority of people but do
affect a subset who use cbd it's
important to know that this is not a
side effect-free treatment and you
should always talk to your doctor before
using it another overlooked aspect of
cbd is the alleged purity of the oil
being sold except for epidiolex which is
approved by the fda all other cbd
products sold are not regulated by the
fda this means there's no stringent
testing or oversight to ensure that what
you're buying is what it's claimed to be
now you may think what a company would
want to sell a product that doesn't work
well it turns out a lot between 2015 and
2021 the fda sent multiple warning
letters to 77 cbd companies for
inaccurate or misleading cbd
concentrations a few cases from the
report are as follows five companies
alleged cbd doses of 21 milligrams two
at 50 milligrams one at 500 milligrams
and another at 1500 milligrams after a
lengthy fda analysis it was determined
that there was approximately zero zip
nada nothing of any presence of any
cannabinoids in the products at all one
company alleged their product contained
26 cbd by volume but analysis determined
it to only be 0.14
less than one percent by volume another
company sold capsules with the
concentration of 25 milligrams of cbd
per capsule fda analysis found it to
only be
0.031 milligrams per capsule there's a
lot more examples but this video is
going on 12 and a half minutes so you
get the picture because cbd is not
regulated by the fta the cbd you're
buying is like a box of chocolates you
never know what you're gonna get real or
fake in conclusion cbd may have pain
relieving effects some cell culture
studies indicate this is a possibility
but clinical trials are needed to verify
it as far as anti-anxiety properties
there's a much stronger indication of a
mechanism in human subjects as to how
cbd may alleviate anxiety and there are
some studies that reflect this obviously
clinical trials are really needed to hit
this home regarding seizures the fda has
approved a cbd medication called
epidialex which reduces the frequency of
seizures across different epileptic
disorders again consult with your doctor
finally all cbd except this one is not
regulated by the fda so it's all a box
of chocolates and is not entirely side
effect free so do your research and talk
with your doctor